[Musik]
ortsbesuch aus solidarität mit
griechenland kommt die eu
kommissionschef in an die außengrenze
zur türkei
dort sitzen tausende flüchtlinge fest
absage die hallen der leipziger
buchmesse bleiben dieses jahr
geschlossen das corona virus verbreitet
sich auch in deutschland weiter und
nachfolge georg bätzing bischof von
limburg ist der neue vorsitzende der
katholischen deutschen bischofskonferenz
was heißt das für den reformkurs der
kirche
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend bei
kristin und mehr guthaben kann mir hier
ist hier nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
dienstag die eu will ein zeichen setzen
heute an der griechischen grenze zur
türkei wo weiter tausende migranten
ausharren die der grenzöffnung der
türkei dort aus nutzen wollen um nach
europa zu gelangen
die kommissionschefin ursula von der
leyen ist aus brüssel gekommen um der
griechischen regierung und ihrer harten
linie den rücken zu stärken
schauen wir uns kurz die situation an
fast 200 kilometer lang ist die grenze
zwischen der türkei und griechenland
größtenteils am fluss evros die
flüchtlinge versuchen an verschiedenen
stellen auf die griechische seite zu
kommen
die meisten bislang nahe dem ort
kastanie und genau dorthin kam heute
auch die eu-spitze annette hilsenbeck
truppenbesuch an der grenze
griechenlands premierminister kyriakos
mitsotakis dort wo griechische militär
es die letzten tage die migranten zurück
trinkt haben die glaubten nach europa
reisen zu können weil der türkische
präsident erdogan erklärt hatte die
grenzen seien offen
dies ist nicht mehr ein
flüchtlingsproblem dies ist ein versuch
der türkei verzweifelte menschen für
ihre zwecke auszunutzen um ihre
geopolitischen pläne zu befördern
heute nun empfängt der griechische
premier an den grenzposten die eu
spitzenpolitiker und erhält deutliche
rückendeckung
die griechischen sorgen sind unsere
sorgen diese grenze ist nicht nur eine
griechische grenze sondern auch eine
europäische grenze und ich stehe heute
hier als europäer an ihrer seite
die eu kommissionspräsident in sicherte
griechenland finanzielle und personelle
unterstützung zu tausende hatten seit
dem wochenende versucht die türkisch
griechische grenze zu überqueren
das griechische militär setzte
wasserwerfer und tränengas ein
schickte die migranten zurück
wir sind zweimal nach griechenland rüber
aber die wurden zurückgeschickt sie
haben uns alles abgenommen ist das handy
das geld sie haben uns beschimpft und
uns zurückgeschickt
nach wie vor haben viele am grenzfluss
evros aus in der hoffnung doch noch nach
europa zu kommen
öffnet die grenzen steht auf den
schildern die die kinder hoch halten
es ist ein wunsch der so scheint es im
moment nicht in erfüllung gehen wird
untergehen life 2 andreas postel an eben
diese grenze andreas guten abend hat die
eu-spitze heute auch was dazu gesagt wie
diese situation zum asylrecht passen
soll in europa dazu heute kein wort beim
gemeinsamen pressetermin am nachmittag
ging es in erster linie darum sich
solidarisch zu zeigen mit griechenland
griechenland sei schutzschild europas
und verdiene die volle unterstützung
dass das asylrecht hier durch den
griechischen ministerpräsidenten etwas
in abrede gestellt wird indem er
angekündigt hatte anfang der woche die
aufnahme von asylverfahren für einen
monat auszusetzen hat für heftige kritik
gesorgt dass hat dafür gesorgt dass an
griechenlands grenzen so wurde
kritisiert die werte europas geopfert
werden
und griechenlands ministerpräsident hat
diesen schritt damit begründet dass er
sagt die werte europas werden hier nicht
in mitleidenschaft gezogen ist eine
bedrohungslage seines landes er müsse
sich verteidigen weil griff weil die
türkische seite die grenzen einseitig
geöffnet habe und dadurch würden
menschen in mitleidenschaft gezogen die
ohne not jetzt plötzlich im grenzgebiet
landen würden sagt andreas postel
herzlichen dank angespannt bleibt die
lage auch auf der griechischen insel
lesbos hilfsorganisationen berichten
dass rechte schläger ein camp helfer und
journalisten angegriffen haben
heute mussten die rund 500 migranten die
lesbos in den letzten tagen erreicht
hatten ihre provisorisch aufgestellten
zelte räumen aktuell ist unklar was mit
ihnen geschieht auf lesbos leben bereits
20.000 flüchtlinge
und jetzt das zweite große thema in
dieser sendung die ausbreitung des
corona virus das hat jetzt
möglicherweise die politik ganz direkt
erreicht ein abgeordneter der cdu
landtagsfraktion in thüringen ist wegen
des verdachts auf eine corona infektion
in quarantäne
sollte sich der verdacht bestätigen
könnte das die wahl des
ministerpräsidenten morgen gefährden
der kampf gegen das virus weltweit
weiter gehen italien meldet heute wieder
fast 30 neue todesfälle und auch in
deutschland sind in fast allen
bundesländern infizierte registriert
stand jetzt fast 200 fälle
was soll passieren mit
großveranstaltungen ist eine der
drängenden fragen die antwort auch heute
er absagen heiko bisa
eine kurze mitteilung die gerüchte
stimmen die messe wird abgesagt mehr als
280.000 besucher wurden erwartet nicht
nur auf dem messegelände sondern in der
ganzen stadt bei kleineren
veranstaltungen die auflagen der
behörden gegen korona waren am ende
einfach zu hoch das heißt oder hätte für
uns geheißen dass jeder messebesucher
schriftlich tag genau anzeigen muss dass
er nicht in risikogebieten war in
letzter zeit und dass er mit personen
aus risikogebieten keinen kontakt hatte
dieses jahr bleiben die hallen leer die
kassen der veranstalter auch vom robert
koch institut kommt die info dass sich
das virus weltweit weiter ausbreitet und
voraussichtlich auch nicht wieder
verschwinden wird
es wird sich eher langfristig so ist die
einschätzung mit allen unsicherheiten
die man auch da erwähnen muss
langfristig etablieren
das robert-koch-institut empfiehlt
krankenhäusern ganze stationen in
quarantäne zu schicken wenn ein
mitarbeiter dort infiziert ist die stadt
aachen entscheidet dagegen wer keine
symptome zeigt darf weiter in den
kliniken arbeiten alles andere wäre in
der praxis nicht machbar
wir müssen uns mit der situation
konfrontiert sehen dass wir eine station
nach der anderen vom betrieb abmelden
müssen die ärztliche einschätzung
lautete eindeutig dass die gefahr für
die patienten dann größer ist als wenn
wir eben jetzt eine solche andere
regelung vorsehen
in genf sollte diese woche der
automobilsalon beginnen er wurde wegen
corona abgesagt und findet jetzt im
internet statt die automobilhersteller
präsentieren dort jetzt die neuheiten
die sie sonst in den messehallen gezeigt
hätten und an den finanzmärkten lässt
heute die entscheidung der
amerikanischen notenbank aufhorchen
wegen der korona krise senkt sie
überraschend den zinssatz um 0,5 punkte
bei aller aktuellen entwicklungen halten
wir sie im internet auf dem laufenden in
unserem live blog auf heute de und in
der heute wer bekommt den zuschlag für
die nächste automesse iaa
seit heute kennen wir die antwort es ist
münchen so die entscheidung des
automobilverbands vdr
damit setzte sich die bayerische
landeshauptstadt gegen berlin und
hamburg durch die messe soll künftig
wieder ein größeres publikum erreichen
frankfurt wo die messe fast 70 jahre
lang stattfand war bereits in der
vorrunde ausgeschieden
die deutsche bischofskonferenz hat einen
neuen vorsitzenden den limburger bischof
georg bätzing
er übernimmt die spitze der katholischen
kirche in einer phase des umbruchs
georg bätzing ist 58 jahre alt und gilt
als liberal
seine größte herausforderung wie soll es
mit dem reformprozess weitergehen
wichtige themen da die entschädigung für
opfer von sexuellem missbrauch dürfen
auch frauen priester werden wie umgehen
mit dem zölibat und wie können
kirchenaustritte gestoppt werden
bobby cherry an berichtet in seinem
bistum gilt georg bätzing als versöhner
und zusammen führer eigenschaften die er
jetzt auch außerhalb von limburg unter
beweis stellen muss bätzing ist die neue
stimme der deutschen bischöfe und wird
direkt nach seiner wahl zum vorsitzenden
für mehr dialog in der bischofskonferenz
ich sage wir brauchen wahrscheinlich
mehr kräfte die noch intensiver zusammen
wirken auch über die arbeitsweise der
bischofskonferenz werden wir miteinander
sprechen
der 58 jährige gilt als reformer in der
vergangenheit zeigte er sich offen für
frauen als priesterinnen und eine
lockerung des zölibats bätzing folgt auf
kardinal reinhard marx dieser hatte vor
drei wochen angekündigt nicht noch
einmal für den vorsitz zu kandidieren
erst vor kurzem hatte marx den synodalen
weg mit angestoßen einen reformprozess
der katholischen kirche in deutschland
den will bätzing weiterführen die
reaktionen auf seine wahl überwiegend
positiv seine wahl zeigt auch dass diese
gruppe die den synodalen weg
weitermachen will
die dieses ausgleichende arbeiten für
die rückgewinnung von vertrauen
unterstützen will dass die sich
durchgesetzt haben bätzing ist ein guter
partner für den synodalen weg für uns
frau wird sich mindestens so einsetzen
wie marx vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen mehr das ist unsere große
hoffnung noch bis donnerstag tagen die
deutschen bischöfe in mainz unter der
leitung ihres neuen vorsitzenden
israel hat nach der parlamentswahl ein
gewinner den aktuellen
ministerpräsidenten benjamin netanyahu
aber auch ein problem
seinen blog von rechten und religiösen
parteien zusammen scheitert knapp daran
die mehrheit zu schaffen und so könnte
es kommen dass die israelis noch mal
dann zum vierten mal in kurzer zeit
wählen müssen dann nämlich wenn die
schwierigen koalitionsverhandlungen
wieder scheitern denn netanjahu hat noch
ein anderes problem schon in zwei wochen
soll er vor gericht wegen des vorwurfs
der korruption nicola albrecht die
meisten israelis empfinden am tag nach
der wahl wohl ein déjà vu denn abermals
erreicht kein politisches lager auf
anhieb eine regierungsfähige mehrheit
auch wenn benjamin netanjahu mit seiner
likud partei deutlich vorne liegt und
das reicht netanjahu um sich noch in der
nacht als großer gewinner zu inszenieren
dieses mal ist es ein so wunderbarer
sieg so zuckersüß ein gigantisches weil
herausforderer willi ganz zeigt sich
zwar enttäuscht aber aufgeben will er so
schnell trotzdem nicht
es scheint als habe netanya nicht die
notwendigen 61 mandate für eine
regierung in so fern werden wir unsere
möglichkeiten ausloten das sind wir es
schuldig mehrere szenarien sind nun
möglich es könnte noch eine wahl geben
oder vielleicht bekommt netanya ein
mandat von einem überläufer aus einer
anderen partei außerhalb seines blogs
zum beispiel aus dem mitte links bündnis
aber auch eine einheitsregierung ist
noch möglich
einst hat die wahl gezeigt um inhalte
ging es nicht
netanjahus unterstützern ist es wohl
egal dass bereits in zwei wochen der
korruptionsprozess gegen ihn beginnen
soll und es spielt für sie offenbar auch
keine rolle dass er nach den wahlen das
demokratische system aushöhlen will das
vorläufige wahlergebnis ist für
netanjahu ein persönlicher erfolg und es
ist ein signal dass auf der werteskala
vieler israelis demokratie und
rechtsstaat nicht ganz oben rangieren
liter news überlebenskampf hängt also
nach dem konfetti regen erst richtig an
koalitionsverhandlungen und strafprozess
zur gleichen zeit das wäre eine noch nie
da gewesene lage wer tritt an gegen
donald trump bei den
präsidentschaftswahlen der antwort
kommen die demokraten in den usa heute
einen großen schritt näher denn heute
ist super tuesday der tag des vor
wahlmarathons fünf kandidaten sind noch
im rennen
der senator bernie sanders liegt nach
den bisherigen vorwahlen vorn gefolgt
vom ursprünglichen favoriten ex
vizepräsident joe biden und dann ist
noch michael bloomberg dabei zum ersten
mal bei einer vorwahl der frühere
bürgermeister von new york city ein
multi milliardär was passiert heute
gleich 14 bundesstaaten wählen es geht
um insgesamt mehr als 1350 delegierte
das sind rund 40 prozent aller zu
vergebenden stimmen
die meisten kommen aus kalifornien und
aus texas wer heute abräumt hat zwar
noch nicht gewonnen aber dann beste
chancen herausforderer von donald trump
zu werten industries berichtet
[Musik]
vor zwei tagen noch hat sie gegen ihn
kandidiert wollte selber ins rennen ums
weiße haus gehen
doch ewig logischer gibt auf unterstützt
nun den ex vize präsidenten joe biden er
soll als moderator den
linken-spitzenkandidaten goalie senders
verhindern wenn ihr der extreme in der
politik überdrüssig seid dann wart ihr
bislang bei mir richtig
nun ist joe biden euer man die meisten
amerikaner wollen kein versprechen einer
revolution sie wollen resultate
zahlreiche demokraten der mitte stellen
sich hinter joe biden bernie sanders so
die befürchtung würde als
selbsterklärter sozialist donald trump
nicht schlagen können senders sieht
darin einen kampf gegen seinen linken
ideen das politische establishment wird
nervös sie stellen sich langsam eine
demokratische partei vor
in der arbeiter und junge leute endlich
eine echte stimme haben
auch er will senders verhindern new
yorks bürgermeister michael bloomberg
erstmals wird der milliardär auf dem
stimmzettel stehen 500 millionen dollar
hat er in seinen wahlkampf investiert
glanzlos aber seine bisherigen auftritte
in zeiten des corona virus inszeniert er
sich als erfahrener krisenmanager
wenn die leute fragen warum sie für
blumberg stimmen sollen sage ich er kann
den job und er wird trump schlagen
es ist ein wettbewerb zwischen dem
linken und dem moderaten parteiflügel in
der nacht könnte es eine entscheidung
geben wenn demokraten in 14 us
bundesstaaten gewählt haben
ergebnisse morgen früh unserer zeit und
auch in tennessee haben die vorwahlen
begonnen doch die waren dort heute
nebensache denn in der nacht ist ein
schwerer tornado über den bundesstaat im
südosten der usa gefegt die behörden
sprechen inzwischen von mindestens 19
toten vielen verletzten und die mensen
schäden besonders schlimm hat es die
hauptstadt nashville erwischt dort
machte der tornado dutzende häuser dem
erdboden gleich entwurzelte bäume
zerstörte straßen und brücken
zehntausende haushalte haben keinen
strom mehr
verheerende bilder aus nashville jetzt
machen wir's schritt in der sendung und
kommen zum sport und das wäre es dann du
christ genau gerade noch im livestream
zu sehen denn in amsterdam gab es die
auslosung zur zweiten auflage der
nations league deren gruppenphase
zwischen september und november
ausgetragen wird
absteiger deutschland werfen nur wegen
der aufstockung von 12 auf 16
mannschaften weiterhin in liga
mitspielen
das team von joachim löw trifft in
gruppe 4 auf die ukraine spanien den
weltmeister von 2010 und auch das team
der schweiz also durchaus machbar und
nicht die hammergruppe wie zuvor
befürchtet
dfb pokal viertelfinale heute und morgen
abend unter besonderen vorzeichen nach
dem tiefpunkt am vergangenen
bundesliga-spieltag mit
spielunterbrechungen wegen hass plakaten
auf den tribünen besonders im blickpunkt
schalke gegen bayern
es war und ist schwer hinzunehmen für
hansi flick wenn eigene fans einem die
freude nehmen am eigenen spiel dem so
erfolgreichen der zeit
ich hoffe einfach dass das wenig auf den
fussball sich konzentriert und dass wir
das ganze so austragen dass wir
letztendlich bessere mannschaft dann
eine runde weiterkommt besprochen
abgestimmt haben sich die schalker und
die bayern was wenn wieder allzu
zugespitzt längst der konflikt der
moderne fußball auf der einen teile der
ultras auf der anderen
was bleibt ist hoffnung dass unsere fans
bisher in der causa hop quasi nicht
auffällig waren die haben sich an diesen
protesten die es ja schon seit vielen
jahren gab eigentlich bisher nie
beteiligt
die allerdings protestierten zuletzt
gegen die eigene nummer eins nach seinem
patzer vom samstag soll alexander nübel
auf der bank bleiben gegen seinem
kommenden arbeitgeber sollten die
olympischen sommerspiele wegen des
corona virus verlegt werden müssen
dürfte tokio gastgeber zu jedem anderen
zeitpunkt bis ende 2020 sein so die
vertragliche garantie auf die sich
japans olympia ministerin stützt das ioc
beteiligt sich bisher nicht an dieser
diskussion um die verschiebung
das ioc setzt sich weiterhin voll und
ganz für den erfolg der olympischen
spiele in tokio 2020 ein ich glaube die
ganze sache besser noch abwarten ja da
sind noch viele fragen offen herzlichen
dank christian für den moment da gucken
aufs wetter der winter winter lässt sich
das da draußen ja eigentlich nicht
nennen im moment heute nacht kann es
dennoch glatt sein und morgen scheint
dann aber oft die sonne
alle details gleich von katja horneffer
um 23 uhr 15 heute ist marietta slomka
für sie da im heute-journal morgen punkt
19 uhr gibt es uns wieder vom gesamten
team danke für ihr interesse und in
allen einen angenehmen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren der regen
ist programmgemäß nach osten abgezogen
und übrig blieben einige regenschauer
zum teil sogar kurze gewitter wie in
frankfurt am main heute mittag das ganze
ist so mittel prächtiges herbstwetter
und mittelprächtig sind auch die
temperaturen
weder besonders kalt nachts besonders
warm besonders kalt ist es derzeit in
lappland minus zehn grad deutlich wärmer
an der algarve mit 20 grad und die 20
grad die gibt es hier auch nördlich des
schwarzen meeres bei uns sinken die
temperaturen in dieser nacht auf plus 3
bis minus fünf grad das reicht also in
ganz deutschland für bodenfrost machen
sie sich also oft gefährlich glatte
straßen gefasst besonders im sauerland
denn da fällt auch schnee regen und zwar
schnee etwa oberhalb von 400 500 meter
einige regen und schnee regenschauer
sind auch morgen über tag noch unterwegs
aber häufig zeigt sich auch die sonne
bei einem wind aus westlichen richtungen
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 3 grad im thüringer wald und 10
grad am nieder oder auch am oberrhein
und am donnerstag beginnt es dann von
südwesten kräftig zu regnen
am freitag kann sich auch mal wieder
eine schneeflocke darunter mischen
der samstag wird für einige recht
freundlich schönen abend noch